schnell bekommen wir denn den impfstoff
und wer wird zuerst geimpft wie lange
wird es dauern bis wirklich alle
durchgeimpft werden
gestern hat die regierung ja ihren
ersten plan vorgestellt
ja erstmal ein gutes goldmarkt berlin
also so wie das aussieht ist es so dass
der impfstoff zuerst ja möglicherweise
den usa hin kommt ja was natürlich
schade ist war auf der anderen seite
kann man natürlich auch so sagen
zumindest die amerikaner können auch
testen mit die nebenwirkungen sind also
von da hat also zweischneidige sagte die
zweite sache ist die werden etwa vier
bis sechs monate brauchen mindestens um
eine gewisse anzahl durch zu impfen so
dass wir auf erden immunität kommen weil
das dauert einfach müssen juristisch
aufbauen
wir müssen die leute impfen müssen sie
sammeln zu sammeln dem stellen müssen
schaffen wir also das dauert dann selber
die priorisierung nach gruppe hatte ich
für richtig weil er halt nur einen
beschränkten dem stoff haben wir müssen
vorstellen also im dezember sollen 50
millionen impfstoffe dasein im zweiten
2021 102 milliarden wird sich
gigantische spiel an
aber wir müssen ja hat bedenken dass wir
etwa vier bis fünf milliarden menschen
impfen müssen ja weltweit also von daher
ist das alles eine herausforderung und
die nächsten wochen und monate bleiben
wirklich spannend das heißt da war als
ich das gehört habe mit dem impfstoff
aber ich sage supergeil
jetzt können wir diesen kleinen videos
mal ein gewitter treten die zweite
gedanke war aber natürlich auch wir
müssen gucken wie lange weiterhin stoff
wie lang ist der schutz des impfstoffes
wie geht es weiter und so weiter also
das bedeutet wir haben noch ganz viele
herausforderungen vor uns also wir leben
eine sehr spannende zeit und bitte die
aha regel nicht vergessen darüber
das danke dass sie das so noch mal
gesagt haben ja jetzt ist die frage es
wird ja ganz oft über priorisierungen
gesprochen sie haben es auch gerade
schon angesprochen
es wird auch dauern das haben sie auch
gesagt trotzdem die frage wie lange
dauert es wirklich bissig den impfstoff
bekommen
also wenn ich sie so ansehe sind sie
nicht in einer risikogruppe
aber vielleicht in einer relevanten
gruppe also man muss jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich sagen es wird mindestens sechs
monate bis ein jahr dauern bis wir alle
in deutschland die geimpft werden wollen
auch mal durchgehen ist haben und es
wird mindestens drei bis vier monate
dauern bis wir die ersten priorisierten
gruppen die durch gamestagen das heißt
also einmal die menschen in den
gesundheitssystemen also ärzte pfleger
und so weiter dann aber auch menschen
die im rettungsteam sind polizei
bundeswehr und so weiter und dann aber
auch natürlich gerade die älteren
patienten die halt und erkrankung leiden
und so weiter
also das ist jetzt ein marathonlauf der
uns bevorsteht
noch mal ganz kurz von herrn
eingeschränkt wann gilt man als
risikogruppe risikogruppe sind dann wenn
sie bestimmte erkrankungen haben wie zum
beispiel eine chronische bronchitis
durch das nach herzinfarkt patienten mit
krebserkrankungen und so weiter und dann
natürlich auch über einbußen lebensjahr
etwa über 60 beziehungsweise 70 jahre
hören sie auf zu einer risikogruppe wenn
die impfung dann mal da ist und man
geimpft werden kann bekommt man die dann
beim normalen hausarzt oder wie darf man
sich diesen prozess vorstellen
also ich glaube wenn ich die grippe
impfung hätte dann müsste ich erst mal
so aus meiner praxis eine art fort knox
machen sicherheitstrakt sie haben das ja
auch in denen aus irgendwann gern sparen
gehört
er möchte es nicht bei den hausärzten
oder abholen lassen sondern in etwa 60
prozent bundesweit und sie sehen ja auch
die brisanz des themas darin dass der
impfstoff in der bundeswehr oder im
bundeswehrkasernen gelagert werden soll
also wie gesagt nicht ohne grund ist der
sitz dieses in hersteller in mainz in
der straße zur goldgrube
rund 70 prozent der deutschen müssten
geimpft sein um wirklich eine immunität
in deutschland herstellen zu können wie
lange würde das dauern können sie uns da
schon eine zahl nennen
es hängt natürlich davon ab wie die
menschen sich impfen lassen wollen und
die bereitschaft ist wie die akzeptanz
ist sind dann möglicherweise nehmen
dürfen ja oder nein aber sie müssen
mindestens man kann seriös nicht sagen
dass man ganz klar sagen aber ich rechne
persönlich damit dass mindestens ein
jahr dauert wird bis wir wirklich 50
millionen durchgeimpft hätten wirklich
konsequent wirklich sehr anstrengen
prozess 50 müssen geben da auch
mindestens ja manche kollegen gehen
sogar von zwei jahren aus und dann ist
die frage wieder ist dann der schutz
ausreicht müssen uns wiederholen also
sind wie gesagt ein spannendes war und
jetzt sparen wir haben es gerade schon
erwähnt will den vertrag jetzt
abschließen mit biontech dass wir
deutschen auch wirklich geimpft werden
können und zwar vor anderen ländern
wie dürfen wir uns das vorstellen wie
sieht das konkret aus also da haben sie
schon die richtige problematik
angesprochen ich glaube gar nicht dass
jens spahn diesen vertrag abschließen
kann
ich glaube eher das ist ja gemacht
worden ist dass die europäische union
das macht oder machen soll da gibt es
nichts sozialen bevor verträge und da
sind die amerikaner wieder schneller an
scheinen zu wie es ist also jetzt spart
macht natürlich druck auf die eu dass
diese verträge abgeschlossen werden
können ja dass wenn ich mich recht
erinnere ja entschlossenheit
europäischen union gemeinsam zu handeln
gemeinsam bedeutet aber hoffentlich
gemeinsam schnell nicht gemeinsam
langsam und deswegen finde ich es sehr
gut dass sich unsere gesundheitsminister
jetzt sparen dafür einsetzen dass wir
jetzt schnell zu potte kommt den vertrag
mit biotech schnellen unterschlagen
ja ja ja und jetzt wenn wir nochmal zu
bionic und zum impfstoff zurückkommen
die firma biotec sagt ja 90 prozent
effektivität hat dieser impfstoff das
haben die getestet jetzt als laie hört
sich das wirklich richtig gut an 90
prozent was sagen sie als fachkompetenz
also auch für den fachmann wird sich das
richtig gut bin ich ganz ehrlich 19
prozent werden
man muss jetzt gucken wie lange hält
diese impfen antwort ja das was ich
damit meine ist ist diese antikörper die
produziert werden gegen den kurven virus
da sind sie sechs monate noch im körper
und aktiv oder ja oder zwei jahre
das ist halt ganz spannend weil wir
haben impfungen zum beispiel die
grippeimpfung praktisch ein jahr verrät
ich danach muss man eventuell mal impfen
bestimmte andere in form halten fünf bis
sieben jahre
manche sogar noch länger also es bleibt
jetzt spannend und abzuwarten wie lang
ist dieser impfstoff wirksam wie lang
sind diese antikörper dieser des
impfstoffes der das sitzt er notiert
beziehungsweise anstoß noch wirksam also
wie gesagt ganz spannend mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren